hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play for we are 1.5
let's take a nappy nap because oh my god
I feel so comfortable and safe in this
house of horrors ah how refreshing
oh good its day how delightful I'm not
dead
what a wonder what a time to be alive
ok I never slept as poorly as I just did
I need to find a way to get in the rest
of the rooms of the house is bound to be
fuel somewhere in here ok
oh and you know what I forgot to do hang
on let me do this real quick too so I
remember and I don't forget next time
always remember to reverse gyrate way
out of bathrooms where areas safety ha
ha ha ha ha is that joke that I made
haha ok so anyway now what I need to do
is I need to find the tool that can open
up the rest of the house so where oh
where would this tool be in the basement
maybe no I didn't actually check the
basement for anything
oh that amazing noise how I love it yeah
I didn't actually check to see if there
were any tools down here I mean it would
make sense that there would be I'm seen
anything yet though ok and that thing
goes to something I don't even know oh I
found a bug apparently you can still
sprint in place forever and ever
either way okay so look where's the
noise getting louder we can never mind
I'm out here I'm out here baby oh oh
this base would give you the creeps I
don't even know if the base we gave me
this much creeps last time I was here oh
okay so anyway I gotta find something
some sort of uh some sort of tool that
can open the thing Thung now maybe one
of these doors ah hello yeah
the firewood a well well well how good
for me this will definitely help finding
the way open to this door over here I
hope it's a sword doesn't mean to make
me look stupid if it's not yeah baby
alright alright alright alright
a garage this is what I was looking for
now let there be fuel let there be whew
how about even better how about a crew
burr metal cabinet looks like lock with
a puzzle
what hey a pinare odd well it looks good
to me I don't know oh wait no I haven't
come on om ma RK IPL I okay that
wouldn't work okay never mind I don't
know I don't know I mean that note I an
incident at the hospital yesterday I was
getting some supplies when I got caught
in the act by a nurse I guess it was
just a matter of time even if it was the
last installment I needed I can't afford
to go to prison I can't afford to waste
any time I can't afford to anyone know
about the experiment I couldn't risk my
life's work so I brought her here
that's quite a romantic date you playing
there boy are you just the delightful
type okay to map the house so ah there
we go see that's um what is that there's
a clue there no there's a clue he's
missing actually wasn't there another
map of the house somewhere else so I
gotta find the piece of the puzzle there
was another map of the house I believe
in here I think I see a right here hang
on a tick it's an old newspaper nurse
gone missing oh okay I thought that
would have been to map
all right so well so what about that so
what about dad okay maybe this spells
something that I can figure out okay
what's the one with the least number of
possibilities got a spell like a name
her run paranoia
ah maybe annoy no no II Oh Oh paranoid
okay yeah my god
I said paranoid what are you talking
about oh maybe I'm paranoid that makes
so much sense in the oven II in the
thing maybe I'm paranoid in the first
note that's that's really smart
that's really cool I got that by uh
using my my brainy weenie there's no
fuel in the garage I don't know what to
do now it starting to get cold I should
light up the fireplace again white
everything go quiet
why did everything go quiet it's never a
good sign when things go ahead that's
how they gotta quiet I didn't want okay
okay caboose key Oh yo yo Co bar barking
the proverb okay all right
I'm sure nothing can go wrong here nope
that make sure seems to have rather
strange side-effects the test subject is
started to forget things it's not just
amnesia either she's forgetting
everything the test subject had
forgotten just about everything where
she is who she is or even what she is a
mixture seems to destroy brain cells
some of the side effects are also
extreme aggression and mutation oh so my
beautiful princess who's got to come
rescue me isn't exactly gonna be lovely
that's okay I don't judge by looks oh
she has a great personality isn't this
some inclination that I should maybe get
the hell out of here I guess I couldn't
go anywhere I'd die in the cold
probably okay I'm just gonna like a fire
but the bad gonna happen while it's
still warm I should try to get some
sleep and think about my next move
tomorrow what you're gonna sleep now why
why would you say horrible idea you just
woke up maybe because he slept so badly
last time he's a little baby a little
wimpy baby man not a super Pro awesome
guy like me you wouldn't dare I'll leave
the door open I don't care cool close
the damn door
am I the only one that sleeps from right
door closed and locked oh I
but stabbers coming to get me oh boy
starboard no no
no no no how many hands you have no no
no how many times do I say no oh good
that noise again oh good for me that
goddamn noise again you're not gonna
think about the knocking you're not a
very bright individual are you okay okay
all right okay all right okay all right
come on come on come on good huh huh huh
we do it will you leading me where am I
going
no okay so I gotta go a long way around
is this what you're telling me
no you Oh shucks what am i doing in here
another linear
there's nothing an arrow so reason go
wherever there's no reason oh you guys
heard those footsteps in the snow right
you guys heard them why would you make
me go the long way around it won't budge
oh good
okay we're fine let's go see what he
wants
I hope he banging down there Oh an open
invitation huh I don't wanna okay that's
just all a dream oh good I wake up nice
and refreshed in my bed what do you
think about that night's sleep a little
weird huh ha ha strange what a horrible
nightmare drums a real gosh I wonder why
all right let's go find out what
happened in that basement
alrighty then
alrighty
oh so no more Choir demons it's just
gonna be a baseline PN you gotta hear
that pauses squeeze what do you got what
the but it was just a dream it was only
just a dream
Oh something was locked in here and it
got out there's something in the house
with me
yeah no kidding dead rats looks like
something has been feeding on them
alrighty then something drawn in the
paper ah is that the ceiling attic
thingy is that some kind of drawing
referring to a hatch of some kind I know
what hatchet is referring to I know the
secrets that you be slinging around I
understand I understand a lot I have to
say this game no ok I could do that to
her camera r-r-r-r-rah don't come down
here rarrr I didn't do that I didn't do
that I didn't know I'd do that okay so
anyway that's all the time I got for
this Bart I'm gonna find out where the
hats leads next part thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for what it is that I've done as always
I will see you in the next week no no no
something is up there
martyr
bud